happy hats day to you happy hats day
dear
Timothy wheat allergy doesn't like clown
oh happy hats day to you
that's me red ever since I was a kid I
never really fit him no one understands
me
we nice traveling this seems to be a
recurring issue he'll angle I don't
think I have an anger issue I think you
got an anger issue are you aware that
that robe that you're wearing isn't
fooling anybody
voila oh my god reading from the world
of the pig
these pigs are mysterious and weird am i
right I don't trust them I think they're
up to something all pinyin is not lady
peek wing giblets that went well
if you're me set sail for piggy island
you tried to tell us but we didn't
listen what do we do now that is where
they went and so that is where we're
going we're gonna get those eggs back
come on we're bird we're descended from
dinosaurs we're not supposed to be nice
Oh
yeah point made time to get angry fire
yeah Wow about that she can shoot
fireballs out of her butt
all in the pinky airborne
he's coming back oh did we win
can we get an ice pack for how
Chuck is that you this is the house oh
my gosh
three DS from the world of the peace oh
my god what's a pig we request the honor
of